We mentioned logs before, so let's actually use them now. Just like exponents
have a base, so do logs. If, for example, like in this function we have here,
our exponent has a base of 2, then so does the log that is its inverse. Let's
plug a number in and try something out. We know that for this function, f of 3
is equal to 2 to the 3rd, or just 8. Using logs, this means that log base 2 of
8 Equals 3. I know this is all very new, so if this sounds confusing or
unfamiliar, that's not a big deal at all. Don't worry. We'll keep working with
these, and you'll come to understand them very well in a short period of time.
Now, we can see more clearly what's going on here if we rewrite this 8. We can
instead put 2 to the 3rd there, and this shows what's really happening. We know
that log base 2 is the inverse of what's happening here. And we can see here
that it really is undoing what happened to the original 3, that input. With a
function f, we input 3 and it output 8. When we input that number, the output,
into the log function, in other words, when we took log base 2 of 8, the output
was the original input. This inverse function, this log function, undid to the
3, what f did to it in the first place. Let's look at this in a different way.
When we input 3 into our exponential function, it spits out 2 to the 3rd. Then
when we use 2 to the 3rd as the input for the logarithmic function, that's the
inverse of the exponential one The output is three again. Similarly if we use
three as the input for a logarithmic function the exponential function undoes
what the log does. In other words two to the power of log base two of three. Is
equal to 3. This is just confirmed, that these two inverse functions behave
just like other inverse functions. F of F inverse of X, gives us X and F
inverse of F of X, gives us X. So, here's a couple for you to try, on your own.
What is Log base 2 of 16? And what is log base two of 64. Giving you a little
hint for how to think about these, try to rewrite 16 as two, two some power.
What power belongs here? And how does that effect what number goes over here?
Maybe you can think about this one in the same way.